all right let's go to Sean in
Pennsylvania hey Sean how are you I'm
all right sir thank you very much for
taking the call certainly how can I help
um it's been a rough year I lost a great
paying job and I'm hustling as much as I
can but I'm making about two-thirds what
I used to I can't keep up my debt
payments anymore the money I've got
coming in covers the budget and a little
bit of debt but I've got a lot of stupid
debt you argue I still have enough cash
to keep paying for a couple months but
do I stop now hold on to that until
hopefully my situation changes what did
you used to make my household income you
see I didn't fully ask and what is it
now it's under hundred okay and it's all
you earning the money no my my wife does
work it's not a high paying job she's a
children's ministry director at a local
church making how much about twenty
thousand a year okay so you went from a
hundred and twenty to about 80 correct
doing what what do you do
Human Resources I was a director in the
company and I have not been able to find
an equivalent position okay but you're
looking and you've been looking you've
been looking for how long a year now the
interesting thing is you know how pizzas
made right exactly yeah so it's a both
gives you insight and additional
frustration all right so what kind of
debts have you got you wouldn't be the
first one I can tell you that so let me
just say okay I only found you last week
and not a couple of years of the listen
no no I'm kidding
I've got them it's $70,000 in consumer
debt actually the last 40 I've taken
probably in the in the last year just to
will keep help keep me afloat there's
more student loan debt in there than I
want to mention didn't go down forty did
it like there was a period of time where
I was completely out of work okay so
let's break it down will you own your
cars I twelve thousand on one car okay
and what's the writ was you get credit
cards credit cards and unsecured debt of
around seventy thousand okay
and a lot of that has been in the last
year by trying to maintain your
lifestyle okay and so how much is your
house payment my house he needs thirteen
hundred okay and how much cash do you
have left about six you know know five
thousand okay
no we're gonna hold that until we get
some of this weathered and you've got to
cut your lifestyle and get on a written
budget and you still make a hundred
thousand dollars a year and even if you
pick out some things that you just say
alright I'm not gonna pay that credit
card I'm gonna let that one go bad pick
out the big one you know or something
like that if something has to be
sidelined but you need a detailed
written budget you guys don't need to
see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there you don't need to
be on vacation people make it on a
hundred thousand dollars a year with
$70,000 in debt they make it on that and
so you know you guys are part of this is
your year when we didn't go ahead oh we
didn't touch protect the student debt
payments or started and my total debt
payments not counting the car is four
thousand two hundred a month okay I'm
sorry
so 70 thousand doesn't include student
loans correct oh how much yesterday loan
debt do you have it's over a hundred
thousand now okay that goes on hardship
deferral for right now
not paying it today yeah okay so you've
got to balance your freaking budget
borrowing to maintain the appearance of
everything's okay is not making
everything okay so we're not going to
burn through cash and we're not going to
borrow to maintain the contest a current
on the payments if you have to get
behind on something to pick what to get
behind on take the hut take the student
loans immediately put them on hardship
deferral no question about that and then
but you still need to get on a detailed
written budget because you should be
coming home with $6,000 and you have a
$1,300 house payment and so you've still
got some leaks here you guys are not
making every single dollar scream with
your budget and you and your wife are
not working together on this at the
level that you have to be that's what's
going to turn the corner on this and
that organization of that money makes it
much more efficient so I always tell
people you feel like you got to raise
when you did it so and then continuing
to hunt and pick up extra jobs and
continuing to hunt for the new career
and all that stuff that's going to turn
the corner on this but you can't keep
you you can't keep burning cash here
whether it's real cash or whether it's
debt cash you've got to get this budget
below your income